[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
société une émission un peu particulière
ce soir il devait y avoir autour de
cette table plusieurs personnes pour
parler du mal-être des urgences suite à
des désistements de dernière minute avec
moi en plateau pour parler de cette
problématique bernard landais vous êtes
le secrétaire force ouvrière du centre
hospitalier de l'hôpital de
mantes-la-jolie bonjour bonjour depuis
et six mois les services des urgences
sont en grève
agnès buzyn a présenté son pacte d'euros
fondation pour mettre fin à la crise d
urgence il se décline en douze mesures
un plan financier avec une enveloppe de
750 millions d'euros
pour autant la grève persiste une
semaine après la ministre met en place
des groupes de travail pour accélérer le
processus
est ce que ça vous rassure c'est pas
fait pour nous rassurer en dans le sens
où les mesures qui ont été proposées par
le même butin correspondent pas
forcément aux aspirations des personnes
des services d urgence une combleront
pas forcément des besoins et des
services d urgence sont en grève ou
réclamer de meilleures conditions de
travail avec une hausse des salaires 300
euros de revalorisation de salaire sont
réclamées par le personnel des services
d urgence en grève vous réclame
également une hausse des effectifs une
meilleure sécurisation des locaux une
reconnaissance du travail en urgence
comme spécifiques et l'arrêt de
fermeture des lits tout sa suite à vos
conditions de travail
quelles sont elles à l'heure actuelle
les sages d'urgence sont complètement
engorgé par des personnes qui n'ont pu
recours à des médecins ce que la
pratique médicale libérale a changé de
moins en moins de médecins ne gagne rien
une désertification et les personnes se
dirigent vers le seul accès aux soins
qui à leur disposition c'est à dire le
centre hospitalier est il son service
d'urgences des gâteries gynécologique ou
général donc ces personnes arrivent on
doit s'occuper des ce qui est tout à
fait normal
malheureusement en termes de conditions
de travail avec un certain nombre de
reliques de milliers de lits qui ont été
supprimés ces quinze dernières années on
parle de 89 minutes ont été supprimés
vous rendez bien compte qu'il est
compliqué de hospitalisés des personnes
donc ils sont dans un box nos
consultations des urgences et les autres
personnes attendent dans les salles
d'attentes des urgences donc on a un
engorgement
les gens ont mal sont pas forcément pris
en charge dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et effectivement il ya
dégradation une incivilité dégradation
des conditions tragiques incivilités
dans ces lieux là trente mille personnes
ont dormi sur un brancard plutôt qu'un
lit la nuit à disposition ça depuis le
1er juillet 2019
alors justement pour désengorger les
urgences une démesure d'agnès busin un
service d'accès aux soins un sas seront
mis en place
il vise à réguler les appels au secours
en ligne ou par téléphone c'est une des
solutions pour réorganiser le service
des urgences il faudrait que madame la
ministre nous dise un petit peu en quoi
une ligne unique d'appel pourrait
vraiment désengorger des urgences si
c'est d'accéder aux urgences du centre
hospitalier que sur la base d'un appel
téléphonique
oui mais ça fait un petit peu fermés un
petit peu comme les pharmacies de garde
je sais pas si c'est vraiment la
solution adéquate
maintenant j'ai cru comprendre que nous
avions le 15 de 17 le 18 le 115 de 110 à
tous tout ça réuni sur une ligne unique
honnêtement j'aurais pas être à la place
de la personne qui prend l'appel
téléphonique parce que il faut connaître
tous les dispositifs de prise en charge
est ce un sacré mais c'est quand même la
ministre a parlé de renforcer les
consultations sans rendez-vous et de
développer la présence de maison
médicale de garde pour aider les
urgences est ce que c'est une des
solutions
malgré la pénurie de médecins les
maisons médicales de garde effectivement
doivent être leur premier recours avec
le médecin généraliste le médecin de
famille à une prise en charge médicale
c'est évident les urgences devraient
normalement être le seul endroit où on
vient
quand il ya une urgence par les pompiers
le samu ou de la traumatologie la grosse
traumatologie j'entends une fracture il
faut mettre un plâtre voir
éventuellement partir au bloc opératoire
pour une pour une opération
donc oui les maisons médicales de garde
oui c'est un impératif maths on les
remplit avec quel médecin quel
professionnel de santé on peut avoir des
infirmières ça pose aucun souci il y en
a décliné il y en a des psychologues
pourquoi pas mais des médecins c'est la
pénurie des médecins qui fait que les
personnes se dirigent vers les urgences
et ça on les remplit les maisons
médicales de garde avec quel médecin ce
soit donc revoir l'articulation entre
l'hôpital et ses centres de garde
oui tout à fait je vais prendre un
exemple c'est paru dans un grand
quotidien national il ya quelques
quelques mois j'en avais pas le conseil
des changes l'hôpital de mantes le
centre hospitalier de gonesse en 95 pas
très loin a déménagé il ya deux ans lors
de la construction cet hôpital ils ont
oublié entre guillemets la maison
médicale de garde
les urgences du centre hospitalier sur
l'année la première année de
fonctionnement augmenter le nombre de
passages augmenté de 67%
c'est quand même un signe que les
personnes vont vers l'hôpital et si
effectivement une maison médicale de
garde qui ado c'est effectivement on
peut diriger vers les consultations et
le nombre de passages aux urgences a
doublé en 20 ans oui oui avec
naturellement les problématiques liées
on en revient aux conditions de travail
ou à la géographie des lieux
si on a un service d'urgence qui est qui
a une jauge de personnes à dix quinze
vingt mille personnes par an si on
double nombre de personnes imaginent et
bien c'est très très compliqué
d'accueillir tout le monde l'hôpital
demande prévue pour 17 milles on en est
à 46 milles c'est très compliqué
d'accueillir tout le monde en même temps
tout le temps je le rappelle agnès buzyn
a décidé d'accélérer la mise en place de
groupes de travail
malgré tout vous allez poursuivre la
grève oui le personnel hospitalier puis
l'inter l'interrogent ans ont décidé de
s'inscrire
de protection de protestation et de
grève le 26 septembre prochain avec nos
collègues pompiers qui aussi souffrent
très forts de leurs conditions de
travail
ce ne sont pas des taxis bus mais on
n'est pas un taxi ne sont pas là pour
transporter les gens mais pour porter
secours à la population les pompiers
vous l'avez dit sont aussi en grève
c'est tout un système qu'il faudrait
revoir alors est ce que c'est un système
où est ce que il faudrait peut-être que
la population s'adresse aux bonnes
personnes on a un médecin traitant d'un
médecin traitant
voilà un sac c'est très compliqué il y
en a de moins en moins peut-être faut-il
revoir l'installation des médecins mais
en tout cas les services d'urgence
doivent être concernés par leur coeur de
métier
l'urgence merci beaucoup bernard landais
je le rappelle vous êtes le secrétaire
force ouvrière du centre hospitalier de
mantes la jolie
merci d'être venu parce que c'est la fin
de ce sept huit sociétés très belle
soirée
[Musique]